[Music]
oh there you go
I love Mrs doubtful I don't know what a
human on this planet that doesn't love
Mrs Doubtfire so it must have been
something else to work with Robin right
it was such a blast so memorable uh I
mean if I never did anything else I made
Mrs Doubtfire and this job came at a
time where I was really worrying about
the mortgage payment and they said you
got a job that's for Robin Williams and
uh it was truly
magnificent experience so yeah I
remember the first day up in San
Francisco it was a gorgeous sunny day
and they said well uh welcome and do you
want to meet Robin I said yeah and he
said he's in the makeup trailer so I
went in he went into the makeup trailer
and he was sitting there and he had a
Hawaiian shirt on and big hairy arms and
legs and cargo pants but Mrs doubtfire's
head that's so creepy
oh give us a kiss
hey buddy nice to see you how you doing
so that and I really never worked with
Robin I worked with Mrs Doubtfire the
whole time because he was in makeup at
four o'clock in the morning I'd come in
for my work and oh that's so funny and
so I I never saw Robin it was always Mrs
Doubtfire it just must be cool as an
actor to be a part of I mean God you've
been a part of so many huge things but
just something that I feel like families
that's just that that was filmed with
such a huge thing in pop culture for
families like it didn't matter what age
you were everybody loved it it's a very
healing film yeah very joyful film and
it has lasted yeah it's classic yeah it
was a classic so yeah I love that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]